me give you a really good piece of
advice never say no for the other guy
don't make a decision for the other side
of the table of why they're gonna say no
just do everything and then let them say
yes to the thing that they like by the
way my friend when you pitch people mix
it up sometimes come in with a lower
price sometimes come in with bravado
sometimes come in with humility when you
actually try to get to 97 people and you
get 17 meetings you actually get the
chance to try 17 different moves if
you're like 99 of people and overthink
everything and have one meeting a month
and one at bat you don't get the chances
to try the different [__] that might
actually unlock what the real answer was
and that's it like like that's the game
like one thing I don't understand so
many of you are just starting out your
[__] and you're [__] fancy like this
entitlement or you're gonna have some
perfect strategy